NEWSFLASH: Kissing is dirty, disgusting, and
also kinda great for your health.
Take that, Duggars!
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and everybody
loves kissing, right?
That’s a thing.
Well according to a new study, it’s actually
a very disgusting thing.
A paper published this week in the journal
Microbiome - can you tell where I’m going
with this? - says that just a 10-second French
kiss, can spread up to 80 million bacteria
between mouths.
This was a study conducted on 21 couples,
who agreed to have their tongues swabbed before
and after a 10-second long French kiss.
Based on that experiment, scientists discovered
that people who are in committed relationships
tend to harbor similar collections of bacteria
on their tongues.
And the more often they kiss, the more bacteria
they seem to share.
To find out exactly how similar those bacteria
were, researchers repeated the experiment
- but this time, they instructed one of the
partners in each relationship to partake in
a probiotic yogurt drink, and then wait a
bit before making out with their significant
other.
Sure enough, the probiotic bacteria - which
aren’t normally found in a person’s mouth
- transferred over to their partner, along
with 80 million other bacteria.
It sounds kinda gross, but keep in mind that
as long as you’re not transferring any infectious
pathogens, increasing the diversity of bacteria
in your body is actually a very good thing.
According to Remco Kort, the author of this
study, kissing is essentially a form of immunization,
enabling you to build up resistance by exposing
yourself to more and different kinds of microorganisms.
So the next time you find yourself at a club,
flirting with an attractive lady… try using
this pick-up line: “Hey baby, wanna diversify
your microbiome?”
Works every time.
What do you guys think about this, any thoughts?
Any amazing pick-up lines you’d like to
share with the class?
Feel free to leave em all in the comments
down below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching - and happy
kissing!